hi everyone it's Jerry I have an
instructive game to share with you from
the late titled Tuesday which was held
on January 23rd on the white end
14-year-old fiday Master artm diachuk
playing as Vladimir kramnick after the
game kramnick reported his opponent for
cheating my own take on this given my
own experience with the game especially
playing online I factored in move times
with this one reviewed it with an engine
looking at Key moments throughout and in
my own opinion uh this was a wellplayed
and honest game by a young talented
player and I really saw no red flags uh
I see moments where others may think
there's a red flag but I don't believe
so anyhow there are a few key features
to take away from this one things to
look for on White's end one a nice
middle game plan on the queen side two a
key defensive idea on the king side and
three a beautiful puzzle rush like
ending let's have a look we kick off
with E4 Sicilian Defense Moscow
variation with Knight
D7 Queen comes out early in this one
white has to be a bit careful once the
queen is challenged where to
go she has a
responsibility E3 is best Out Of Reach
of Knight
C5 Knight C5 still white is there in
time to secure E4 Bishop B7 security for
the White
Queen and
B5 what move would you play here as
white feel free to pause the
video okay as mentioned at the start
here's this nice middle game plan on the
Queen's side and it involves a couple
key pawn moves kicking off
with B4 this is a best move a proceed
with caution move I should note creating
four
weaknesses of the four weaknesses I'd be
most concerned here is white about the C
file weaknesses given black has this
half openen C file very easy to one day
see a black major piece exploit one of
these two now the moments I've seen B4
be effective are moments like this where
it hits with
Tempo Black's reaction is defensive and
white now has time to follow up with
A4 do know the main idea behind B4 it is
not just to attack the Knight it is to
fix the B5 Pawn so that when A4 is there
this pressure becomes too much on B5
it's now a point that cannot be
maintained
it's hit three times defended once black
has to give it up and with it give white
a half open a file and a ready-made
Target in
A6 this will be White's primary focus
from here to Simply pile up on the weak
link white will also as we will see have
to juggle some defensive moves on the
king side but for now at least the focus
is on the A6
Pawn castles Bishop B2 Knight F4 white
hangs on to the bishop and black forms a
battery lining up a sacrifice on the
king's side one way or the
other we continue here with Rook F to
A1 if white wants to prevent a sacrifice
on the king side he can with Knight to
D2 this allows the queen lateral defense
against those
tricks and in this one though Rook F to
A1 I believe you could play this move
without any serious depth of calculation
knowing that right around the corner now
for white is Bishop F1 and Bishop G2 and
the bishop on G2 is known to be a
fantastic kingside
Defender black goes in for the sacrifice
it's not a winning sacrifice it's also
not a losing sacrifice we're entering in
uh we're entering an interesting
position no it's the capture on G2 so
that the king is pulled a rank forward
so that black can now take on
H3 uh that much more forcefully with
check only move Knight G4 and what do we
do
here problem on H2 potentially for the
moment it's covered problem here with
the Queen White has to be accurate
spent some time at this moment found the
best move Bishop F1 saying you take my
queen I take yours I'm up to peace you
want to exchange Queens I'm cool with
that black really cannot go down that
path what would this look like if black
takes the queen here we're just
exchanging queens and a position like
this the two minor pieces outweigh the
Rook this Knight once on D5 will be
worth a rook
so both Queens are saved black continues
with F5 what's the plan open up the f
file sacrifice on F3 and give Ma on H2
but white is there just in time securing
F3 and saying even if one day you get to
H2 no problems I can hang a
left very good Defender this bishop on
G2 Bishop
B7 the mtic follow up now that the
defense a couple defensive moves have
been played on the king side white is
ready to continue with the queen side
play B5 what else to play here how else
to justify the battery along the a
file now black has a move here that
keeps him in the game he doesn't find it
in the game black plays
A5 computer points out Bishop H4 is best
targeting f too karnick doesn't come up
with that plays A5 I believe in a way A5
is saying I don't want to exchange too
many pieces I don't want to subject
maybe my Bishop uh to some attack one
day I believe uh with this Pawn still
around uh getting at this B7 Bishop is
not as easy if there's an open B file
you can easily see a major piece maybe
put pressure on it a bit more stable a
piece the bishop on B7 with the pawn on
B5
so after A5 white is in a winning
position uh doesn't find uh the best
move here uh plays the most natural move
I believe which is to take the pawn on
A5 now what is best in this
position this is considered best now I
must admit if a move like this is played
this to me would be somewhat of a red
flag um
i' be like why can you get away with
taking this Pawn opening up The Bishop's
eyes to a few more squares and why would
you be inviting The Rook to now take on
F5 and invite another piece into the mix
this seems a bit uh scary to play in
this way but there's a tactical
justification for taking on
F5 uh this would really show some
excellent board Vision in my opinion
being able to play at this faster time
control and being able to shift gears
away from this attention along the a
file what is the point I'm getting at if
you take on F5 and black recaptures on
F5 white would have Queen C4 check and
we see this Knight will next fall that I
believe would be a big adjustment for a
human to make in a Blitz game like this
you've made so many moves focused along
the a file to then all of a sudden find
a variation where you shift gears and do
something along a rank like this anyhow
the best move not
found Rook takes a rook takes Rook Rook
takes rook and the followup here is
D5 black still apparently could be in
the game if Bishop H4 is played in this
position but he doesn't find it in this
one it is D5 and it's pretty much a win
for from here for white only a 30 move
game uh this is a formation by the way
you'll sometimes see in a sicilian
zikov three
pawns going right after this E4 Pawn one
way or the other um after either capture
black will be able to push through with
E4 so this is Black's aim to eventually
get this Pawn established here and try
and scare away the F3 Knight the key def
one of the key defensive pieces on the
king side we continue with Knight takes
D5 Bishop takes Knight Pawn takes bishop
and now black is able to get in E4 but
do know the material count here white is
up a light Square Bishop white can
afford to give back some
material he goes in with Rook to
A7 even if uh you take this Knight
uh there's many ways to approach this
you could take with the Queen the bishop
this is not some narrow path to Victory
here for
white this is what kramnick does play he
goes ahead and takes the Knight with
about 35 seconds thought 35 seconds of
thought and I believe uh a lot of the
calculation was already done here by
white during uh Kick's move uh he comes
up with the best move forceful move
Queen E6 check now what I would like to
point out is if white takes the bishop
black would be
winning in a really interesting way I'd
like to highlight a few variations here
before we look at the move played in the
game Queen E6 check so if white takes
the bishop in this
position black would be winning with the
following check on H2
and then not Pawn takes bishop or queen
takes Bishop white would be winning in
both of those cases let me point out why
if you take with the pawn the king is
able to escape you could promote to a
knight but apparently the king is
Slithering away and this is eventually
going to collapse additionally if you
take with the queen and then take here
and then land a check it seems like
black going to be getting mated or
Black's going to mate white after King
C1 but white can take the knight in this
position this is a beautiful queen
sacrifice it's a Checkmate in four for
white it would be with Rook takes
G7 and pick your favorite Retreat move
with the
Rook couple moves from here and it will
be
Checkmate the only winning move for
black in this position right here is
this sparkling move Knight E3 check a
move you might describe as uh an
interference move and also a clearance
move it interferes with the Queen's view
of
E2 and also clears the way for black to
one day defend G7 let's see what I'm
talking about if white first of all runs
with the King he gets hunted there's
some king walk up into the center black
is winning with this octopus Knight on
E3 combined with the black queen if you
take with the pawn it'll be a mate in
two on E2 and if you take with the queen
well now black can take the bishop with
check and be there just in the nick of
time promoting and
defending
G7 so I wanted to point that out that's
a really cool move in this position
right here Knight to E3 the only winning
move for black as tempting as these two
would be the captures on
G2 okay in this game it is the most
forceful easiest one to calculate for
white as well it is with Czech in the
game Rook F7 is
played the only other option really okay
you can't afford a queen exchange so
let's look at what would happen if King
goes to the corner white would have this
as the only move Bishop takes G7 and
then you could take the bishop with
check any king move and queen G7 is mate
and the only other option therefore is
to block on F7 and this here would be a
one minor piece ending these guys are
all passed and
connected completely winning here for
white what is played Rook F7 and this
game finishes up very nicely with Rook
A8
check Bishop
f8 Rook takes Bishop check karnick had
about 12 seconds at this stage and just
let his time run out it's a forced mate
the only move is to take with the
King Bishop A3 check would
follow and here's Just One path straight
to make King G8 Queen check rook f8 and
queen takes Rook game
over what' you think of this
one anyhow Feel Free as usual to leave
any feedback to this video in the
comments section below I hope you
enjoyed it and maybe took a thing or two
away that's all for now take care
bye